so podcast Happy New Year with Rodrigo
Torres right here yeah man
Happy New Year everybody how you guys
doing yeah guest joy Medina in the house
hola what's up guys just joining us here
that's right he's working a new movie I
just saw my facebook our location with
five big-ass tanks that's a story right
now tell me that this came out fresh
story details right
we had the Incredible Hulk on the show
the guy that just stole that they
credible oak wood yeah Joe McQueen fool
what happened they jumped Superman
Superman who hangs out at dog over there
give me money who got job yeah Joe's
telling story on um on the face but he
got jump and they [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
up Superman and he knocked his teeth out
today I use kryptonite did you can do it
normally yeah yeah a little everybody
will stay at this fool with the math and
all this and that somebody money yeah
man if somebody stay with that for
smoking kryptonite away pushy and
they've gotten into fights or
altercation upon the street
the crazier one is Batman special news
bulletin
what no I don't know did I come through
the live wire Oh Hollywood a Superman
ass beaten oh yeah his ass be right and
your microphone tell me again the Batman
one was the craziest
don't forget about man you feel me for
the Pokemon every week I wish him and
don t attack of the killer zombie well
so what's up for the Superman got beat
up right there knocked his teeth out
then people were talking smack and then
Batman joined in to beat him up or get
his own he hears no no Batman man yeah
what the in the documentary about them
it was about the Hulk Batman Wonder
Woman Superman and some other food it
don't matter man but Batman is crazy
that food talks about how you to be here
to be an assassin for the mob mob and
you know I tested by the documentary all
the Batman suit Joseph stoked I'm not
proud of
yeah he was like George Clooney bro
alright quick question is this the
Superman that got his ass kicked the guy
from the documentary yes sandy sandy
Dennis Electress out of towners I came
out of town but that fool was like
hardcore video talking about you he was
hardcore like to the character like if
we had to go smoke a cigarette he'll go
home cuz no one oh but to catch up
smoking say would be nice remember the
smoke that's right his ass kicked either
you're gonna stay together sued back
nobody wants to see I'm with Jim willows
remember
but to get justice cuz that's what
that's real that's funny do ya oh these
[ __ ] up you know superheroes about
people dressed up in costume and have no
more lives it's true in thing is I don't
mind these guys when they have like nice
costumes but I he ever see like the
spider-man is all skinny in the saggy
the we're driving and and [ __ ] Lisa
pointed all this sad a spider-man
Japanese movie kick-ass and how people
are actually regular people because we
just took fight crime remover in Denver
we saw that black fool yeah yeah yeah
dude a Colorado in Denver real people
like yourself know they dress up like a
hot make up their own dumb you say Omega
[ __ ] man right and it dressed up with
a roll costume with their actual weapons
and they walk around the whole streets
fighting crime well that's cuz he had
his own little outfit made up from like
a cross between a different little
handful of superheroes and like x-men
mix with Jaguars yeah and like with them
too but these are actual superheroes
that fighting crime here we're talking
about asking for change they're fighting
poverty like when we had the Incredible
Hulk here Joe McQueen he knows the whole
movie we close the show with him he was
doing original Bill Bixby one yeah he
knows all that [ __ ] I did obsessed I'm
pretty German they had a intervention on
Facebook for Joey Quinn - it's great
acting and go back home well he was
posting some crazy [ __ ] dog remember
like he was getting all suicidal and
like I don't
if I'm gonna live another day damn what
are we your movie
no definitely commit suicide there
my career is even worse I'm late like
most actors including myself you put in
a set there's a tank I'm gonna take 10
photos aw yeah that's right
nowadays we do things only for those
shots there's no more yeah we just were
yeah we just want to Instagram pictures
I'm gonna selfie yeah once we're done
with good leave [ __ ] we're done it's
true man let's uh our dream is article
we're like young people I'm saying young
people who are under 22 they don't know
how to hold a relationship like we're
having a relationship just talking you
and I could they used to other friends
been on Facebook or on Instagram so when
they meet a real friend and they they
get to long that guy becomes a bigger
[ __ ] because everybody that [ __ ]
if you computer compare them to your
friend on Facebook oh hell yeah but they
don't have those interpersonal skills
who I mean in order for you to know
morning everybody used to their likes
you know they like hearing a little buzz
like in a casino you know like that
makes me pay everybody happy
checking your lights other likes 200
likes to like whatever I think you feel
good it makes you feel good that you get
allies you know you're part of this
social media world somebody likes you oh
you're a real life people are quiet they
don't tell you I like you over and over
oh the pressure would that be join with
dinner every day a thousand people give
you a hug oh yeah that'd be [ __ ] up
break stop leave me alone or I got it
I'm good or whatever you know I mean but
okay let's say let's say we weren't in
show business say we weren't doing
comedy would you guys be that heavy in
social media yeah call them out that a
mom maybe how about you Joey no no I
don't think so man I think not even
abroad I think I'll do it in the
beginning like I do everything like I
get into it every every app every social
media I get into it I'm gonna pops yeah
for like a week or two and then I'm like
I'm good and and I only use now the ones
that I have to use that everyone uses
you know communication Twitter the
communicate and sell your stuff and all
the other [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] done man like
you know I got into buying and that you
know that I'm like a [ __ ] 7 second
videos I'm like hey I don't want to do
that it was just after a while it just
gets too much I'm like I have enough
things to do you know when you forget to
masturbate because you're too much on
social media there's too much social
[ __ ] media somebody in the bathroom
yeah the [ __ ] gentleman back in the
old condo days when comics would be in
the condo in the back in the VCR yeah it
was a visa he's watching it and [ __ ]
their knees freaking joke and he doesn't
stop I come in and he's just still
jerking off I'm like all right I just
went to the room like that's [ __ ]
rude should've chosen bro it routes it
through hot water on that fool dog a
roommate or a comedian he's a comedian
he was a comedian I don't know if he I
don't remember I think I think he was
the opening act or something but I don't
like some people are not like some
comics you could tell the career not the
career is done but um they don't do
social media as much you know like
Willie the more these capsule actually I
see really on it more a lot more started
way more over the last couple years yeah
because before he didn't do it because
you know Willie's personality is
different but now he knows how to get
his personality on social media but yeah
Rudy doesn't Rudy doesn't can't hit but
Instagram bro well he still those Flyers
man that's he's a tsunami we still
passes on fire come on Rudy
Philip Minnie list now Matt when I was
coming over here I saw this is DS ad
right and he had everything I used to do
don't do no more like I was the post
office the post office and they had like
a little case or a bunch of like letters
are in there it's like animal info a
weird being there because the litter
with a metal case was glass next to
stamps and the letter they were written
were from 1940 but even in 2007 teen
they they look ancient now yeah we look
into this place case dear my roles and
oh I was reading a letter right cuz a
black woman - black woman 1942 okay she
said in her words cuz this woman had
just moved to Phoenix right from the
south or from the step from LA I guess
okay she moved to Phoenix she was
talking about her garden but her the way
show the way she said it was fine and
she said I'm they got me up in a desert
now she brought the flavor to the
English like oh so in there and on the
case also they had stuff like a lot of
used to do Joey Medina Oh same tapes to
send tapes all the reels were there MPR
all of our cd-rom you know how the cases
tire now time and I remember her Medina
were the first dude that had a [ __ ]
together like you know I think I was
fluffy you know although food but didn't
have structure as far as the business
thing organizing organ I hell now how
many tapes that you send a week you were
harshly bad house in her or anything be
you are the first guys to have a laptop
yeah yeah not sure I remember I bought
it right when I moved to LA so 100
[ __ ] years ago but I said empty oh
you said empty cassettes VHS cassettes
then I have two boxes to mail in because
they were a certain shape and then I
will have this machine that would just
put the one video onto the other of them
yeah dub him really quick and I would do
that and then I would always have like a
personal message on the beginning of my
before I do the stand-up I had one where
I jumped off remember that
open the other thing was me on a big
tower with a bungee cord around me and
go and look if I could take a chance on
this bungee cord you could take a chance
on me and broke people you bring it
through walls it's crazy [ __ ] like that
had then I would have stuff I would have
me do it like doing karaoke but dress
yeah you know those videos things you
would go in like with a friend like a
character and then you would sing into a
video video yeah I would put that on
there right behind I had a production
that was food I figured I want these
people to like be entertained you know
what I mean
and now I'm too [ __ ] late he'd even
pick up the phone to get a booking but
yeah I used to do all that [ __ ] when I
first started Oh the wildest thing you
did like that number you would just you
would send the tapes or you were send to
everybody
yeah oh look a list like yeah oh you
were living at the post office
yeah yeah back in the day there was a
book that was a there was a boy an
auntie
well yeah about the book the Majlis all
stand up yeah I don't know what I was
from but it was a book where all the
clubs were on there all the Booker's
names everything cuz there was no
internet and you were so - yeah
everybody and the thing is because it
was a book and he came out once a year
or whatever sometimes those people
weren't there anymore so you got to be
careful you know know that stuff cuz
wasn't like the Internet you'd go right
now find out who books where right it
was a [ __ ] book and if you bought
that book that book was like the Bible
it was expensive and whose expense owes
more than $200 because that's the one
that I supposed email time selling for
three or whatever back in the day or so
probably yeah and daddy when I was was a
hustler man he was eating that book was
called the national comedy it was
official official like like if you know
like it was ahead like the book is for
the improperly I'll tell you what number
to call and who booked it okay and it
like I think it was and then the Emperor
they know I have one of them it was Jeff
Jenna I wanna yeah yeah that's right
it was a big Booker back then you know
fine improv open mic gigs and then they
had agents to later agents at management
companies they had production companies
they had or anything in show business
that hired talent they had that their
publicist they had all that [ __ ] wow man
I wish I could use that book right now
[Laughter]
the only tape I ever sent to I said a
VHS of me was an eight-by-ten and I
don't know who helped me write my bio
Poli Joey and I put it all together and
I sent him to Abraham's a new yeah yeah
yeah I send it to them they send it back
over you know something we're looking
for right now but they send it I said
one to the Icehouse - yeah yeah Helene
whatever they was or Eileen I think you
like this we don't you know you're not
ready to be headlining
you know and sure who said that um you
know you know there's too much
competition for the feature spots and we
hire and that we have our own openers so
that was there dude next out yeah I got
that same letter dude at that same
letter I even sent a video in a letter
to Saturday Night Live dude you're Lorne
and of course they I never got no
response back but enjoy that the
bumblebee bro whatever cuz you never
know man it was taking a chance talk
about joy with you know was his hustle
bro my fault never gave up and what's up
with that drive what are you getting
from boxing this year being a cop with
the phone I think being in boxing yeah
because it's just that that every day I
would wake up and okay I got to do it
something else I got to do something
else got to do sometimes and I still do
it to this day but I do it I think
smarter and I do it I do it less because
before I was just throwing [ __ ] out
everywhere just see whatever hits you
know every lands but now you got to be
more precise because there's so much
[ __ ] out there - so many comics out
there or so so called comics out there
you don't mean it's that little it's
that the quality is completely different
the way they used to be before you knew
when somebody was good they were good
now people are headlining that I'm like
this case
he's got 15 minutes what the [ __ ] he
doing with the rest of the time you know
what I mean it's just stretchy yeah and
you just like you never know
go long we really get to about how you
said we talked about Rodrigo that you
made us south their best table good
actually did I was gonna do a class or
something but this was years ago this
was back when I lived in living they
were paramount cuz i what i did was i
saw another video and I'm like I can do
better than that
yes that's what it was yeah and I think
I was I was gonna form a class but I
don't think that happened I don't
remember it was a long time ago a real
long time comedy class how many hardcore
fools came in there and you were like
come on man well okay I told I taught a
couple classes but it was like it's a
haha whatever comedy boot camp yeah and
it was and I try to really do for free
because I'm like I felt weird charging
but then there's no weird huh yes like
foot free or by the Roma ha me was this
is I would have the comics go up there
and do like three minutes and then I
would critique them and I'm dude I'm not
a dick I'm not like like you know you
should kill yourself you know to honest
you know I'm more like I always say it
the nice way and then this one [ __ ]
guy he was like oh yeah you're just
bitter oh but I know cuz I was younger
then but it was like you know you're
bitter I [ __ ] I forgot [ __ ] that you
never even gonna learn [ __ ] you
stupid [ __ ] like that's when I'm like
[ __ ] you and I walked out and like I
don't need to do this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
am i doing so I think next time I've
ever do anything like that again I'm
just gonna charge cuz then people gonna
be [ __ ] they you know that value to a
value to it and they they want to be
there not to step on you but did anybody
that you taught in that comedy class or
critique today are they still around
anyway remember I really don't
I turn right now man I was when I went
to have walked into the Greg Dean comedy
classy huh
I haven't seen anybody in that class I
was only one day but everybody other
therefore the third class we're walking
around at they're like big time there's
Lobos man if you're fun funny or a
little bit funny you're gonna get robbed
by these comedy classes cuz you know
break you down there's a first one to
teach you the basic comedy writing
that's all you need right how to write
jokes kids if you don't care cuz your
think about how to be funny you know how
to structure the joke but then in other
place another class there um how to a
feature hot a headline how do you get
booked
how did getting further producers 1 2 3
4 that $2,000 already good damn with
that money is like [ __ ] you could get a
real job or do something real good with
it you know it's like it's it's the
thing is there's people there's old
they're too many classes for too many
things for people who really want to be
a comic I believe take take a good class
on how to write and then that's it and
then watch comedy that's what you got to
do watch comedy because you never know
what your style is gonna be into a few
years into it really you know what I
mean it's rare that somebody opens up
the way they're gonna be 20 years from
now could you develop as a person
develop how to comically learn how to
deliver the lines you learn how to be
more comfortable on stage cuz every
comic sounds like they're doing an act
in the beginning you know especially and
I and I'm not saying this against female
but female comics you can see it more
like they'll do that hi yeah and they
shake their head like uh-huh I'm like
nobody talks like that yeah
and I go they're always new because
they're not comfortable yet they feel
like they're doing a monologue instead
of a conversation you know I mean you
always know where like a young comic
when he opens up his relationship joke
like where's all the couples whether
these people whether that people you
know it's all cheerleaders it don't go
up on stage in the yeah they don't start
posing their laugh to spin around in a
circle they do for four minutes they're
doing all kinds of acrobats and I'm like
well do tell a joke man and they never
got a regular name hardly you know I
mean it's talent John Smith it's always
here
thankee come on just just just just tell
some [ __ ] joke dude
you know they did they do too much pansy
with the DJ jump and say Paisley start
doing a dismembered ladies they turn
that [ __ ] off my intro and they'll play
everything like what are you [ __ ]
doing an impersonation of Pandora
[ __ ]
are they doing this play music music
I've seen that too and it's just like
it's horrible cuz they're doing I think
in my mind they're doing to me they're
it's all an act they're trying to put
this act out there I'm like don't do an
act be funny be funny in a natural way
and then when you're natural like that
dude it you can get away with anything
you really can you know I mean but it's
just when you're doing some kind of
[ __ ] weird act and then I feel bad
like I like to perform for everybody
right but I'll feel bad when I go to
like a regular room and there's mixed
audience and you see like a comic like
that doing that kind of thing I play
this song and you and I'm looking at the
white people from out of town looking
each other like what the [ __ ] are we
watching yeah this is this is B et like
what the [ __ ] am i watching
they're just once they got one they got
one level one one dimension when
dimension and that's it and you can't do
that when you're a comic you just can't
you know what I mean
do you think I got to be a dimension
that everyone could enjoy and do you
think that's where lack of having joke
so they move around dance around yeah so
it's like [ __ ] smoke and mirrors you
know what I mean I know my you can't
show to a regular show man with a
difference of the comedian and BJ like
Steve Harvey to do ten minutes
I can't be dressing up and [ __ ] rest up
hardcore break yeah they tell you get a
respect the stage it were tortillas dog
we all respects the stage more it's
[ __ ] material good material that's
what age not a [ __ ] beauty contest
you know but it's out there well choose
me out man like the people who are like
it's different like no we're we're
stand-up comedians you know we perform
on stage you know people pay tip money
for drinks to watch it make some people
jokes but there's people on Instagram I
have like a million followers bro just
doing like one minute of silly stuff
yeah right and it's always starts off at
this meanwhile me me at the club right
but let me at the club and in there
dancing and me an hour later and it like
same girl different pose throwing up
somewhere nest up 200,000 likes yeah I
don't know watching a video or tits
a little combination of both or get it
right and then a lot of young people
watching it and there are this person
made up I'm gonna be in Phoenix for a
meeting greet and everybody we're gonna
go to North Carolina we're gonna go here
and I'm like I feel like I don't feel a
stirring she's never going here
she is never going there they love you
don't know who she is what the [ __ ] you
do do that meeting greet juggle that was
me I wrote that but honestly like if you
if you could be funny like on Instagram
and get a million are likes you know but
but it's tough to transcend that into
our 30 minute show they don't I just did
a show in
in Houston and I did it at this place
called Fitzsimmons I think it is
Fitzgerald Cheryl yeah they do have been
tears yeah dance it's it's a big club
for two doors yeah two stories so I was
there and it we did well it was a
sold-out show it's it's not that big but
it's a nice little venue and the guy
bartender was telling me that earlier
that day during the day it was sold out
from a YouTube girl she said he said the
tickets were 100 bucks she went up there
for about 20 15 to 20 minutes and just
read comments from her YouTube page and
that's all she did and and people were
paying it was patch of a red lipstick I
don't know I don't know Amanda Knox
I don't remember was but he told me and
I'm like eh you [ __ ] serious heels
yeah and she's so tons of merch and she
didn't do anything but just read
comments from her YouTube page that's
[ __ ] crazy that's crazy a whole
different level
like that guy we had a guy we were at
our Fort Lauderdale though the guy who
came in on Sunday and did 11 o'clock
show sold out a hundred dollars a ticket
uh-huh and I'm doing a meet-and-greet
he'd only did 20 minutes the meeting
Green lasted longer than the show and a
little white girl knew he was a guy
named Wayans who was Middle Eastern
uh-huh and he has like he just sup with
our unicorn a unicorn and he had a
little a wooden horse and he gets those
goofy stuff and her little girls go
crazy [ __ ] I'm gonna hate on him I'm
gonna call homeland security on his ass
and he sold like around $7,500 in merch
35 bucks and hell yeah and I was talking
to one of the waitstaff there yeah man
the dads of these little girls were like
with her head down that they don't know
understand what they're paying for right
yeah no [ __ ] getting robbed basically
you know yeah that's of course they are
Casey - there was another one of those
dudes in the day had a little show that
shows cuz they can't sell drinks all
they do is sell food right sodas but
dude we deliver Talent and it's just not
challenged it's not like a trick we
learned yesterday it's something we've
been developing for years and years and
years and we we you know most of the
time we land it you know but these
little [ __ ] I mean god bless him I
wish I could do that [ __ ] - you know
what I mean
but but I don't know I just don't get it
either I don't get it either
dude they were all right do you think
it's going with
the way the everything's fast short
attention spans you can give them real
fast and that's it nothing more there's
more kids watching it you know a lot of
kids like Isaac who's armed 12 they
don't know stand up no you're not stand
up but they know this they know this
person is really really funny or tablet
oriented funny in a short way sometimes
they're even not like there was this
girl was following he followed me
because she was hot as [ __ ] she's got a
kazillion you know sceles
yes yes that's what I'm talking about
okay yeah yeah yeah she doesn't do
anything so yes he's rose and I was
following I'm like this girl is hot but
she's but I'm a greedy doesn't do it
she's not mean she'd it's not a jerk on
there but you could tell she's a little
cocky like yeah that's me like should do
any I'm Bank okay guys I'm gonna do a
video tomorrow me buying coffee me watch
when I get my movie me huh
you don't need that [ __ ] ready she's
probably making millions of dollars
doing nothing what does she got to work
I mean she started out working Oh God
hey guys should do a video like um
because me me baking me cooking and she
just is up with the old I get like a
1950 sexy
you know one of those different Stepford
Wives oh yeah apron you know to cook
with a nice little hair and then she
goes may come me cooking right and it's
all live with little but in reality that
you put on her pajamas and [ __ ] up
here and she start dancing all crazy
five hundred thousand likes I don't
[ __ ] like how does she do it like
what like I'll hire a hot [ __ ] just to
do that and get and pay their the thing
is you have to be hot yeah how to be how
you can't your ugly ass chick is I see
some comics try to do that oh well
they're not even doing anything extra
hot but then I watch I've seen other
girls though on their that are hot ish
but they don't have that many
followers either you know like I've seen
porn girls that that kind of show a
little bit of some more but you know not
all everything I'm like that's sexier
than some [ __ ] chick buying coffee
you know what I mean but why does she
only have four thousand likes and four
I'll die right now for four I'll take
some 4,000 likes but you know um in this
other [ __ ] gets 400,000 lights cuz she
bought coffee I don't get it so um that
uh what are the one of the things Islam
what is it um go on
no I just think you know it's like and I
sometimes I try to do that I came up
with a character you know my friend yes
grandpa Fred and I love him and that's
that's like a $1200 mass dude she's
dirty grandma oh she does a character
yeah no but she calls herself dirty
grandpa okay you guys should hook up
broke yeah but it was very difficult for
me to do grandpa Fred because it's not
me at all it's a complete different act
yeah
I feel awkward doing it you know I mean
ja I know what what what joke do you
feel like when you're doing other
people's jokes yeah it feels awkward but
it's like it but but it's it looks so
real and it in it's so authentic looking
I know I can do something with I just
I'm not sure what yet well how'd you
come up with that I just bought it I
bought the it's a $1,500 mass or $20
mass but I bought it for 500 on eBay
okay and then I bought the $600 gloves
and then
oh man has yeah yeah and then I'm like
you know what I'm gonna do something
with this and I just when they decided
to do it and the dirty at 12:30 show and
yeah and yeah and he killed do it I got
two standing ovations man cuz he really
thought it was a 90 year old man damn
yeah and then I go up there's a veteran
of World War two veterans that's what
he's at though if they don't know yeah
yeah one time actually open for myself
at a show I did Grandpa Fred thence
there was a middle act and and I came
back and I did a did me is me so that
was cool like this right here this white
kid who put a big-ass snail on his face
escargot organs right hey
1.6 million views three thousand and
eight comments okay that should have
like let's start no but I would like it
do it but it's no talent but they're
doing a meet and greet - that's
ridiculous I was messing with that big
old albino alligator yeah meanwhile for
Robles when I get people who are do a
show in Irvine January 29 he's a snail
you gotta get a snail to get to like
yeah man
see that's a little help Alfred right
right but like like you're like you're
that chick with a put Alfred in a video
I pretty sure it would it get two
million let's do a lot
I think it's curiosity what's she gonna
do next dog and I mean and you seen the
Porsche I was only get four thousand
like but the thing is the Porsche cars
on the internet already have like a
thousand hours of footage you know I
already seen that you've never seen what
that girl looks like naked yet yeah and
you kind of wonder yeah exactly I think
element a surprise but I mean I ain't
into it but dude but I don't like how
like what like do they feel bad inside
like do they ever turn off the phone and
go god damn why do people like me like
I'm not doing anything for something I
don't think they living in my mom's
house but and I think it's to the
presentation is nice and clean a poster
when you do see a chick to slip into the
mom's house with a Del Taco Cup a bong
and they're you know dirty socks another
thirty monster Rosa does a video every
day yeah but he's getting a lot of PIP
followers too you know I mean he's more
he's more he's famous on Instagram but
not famous doing stand-up that's that's
why I'm doing all the stuff I'm doing
I'm trying to do movies and this and
that because I'm like I gotta get more
popular somehow something bro and do you
think that that's the new way of doing
stuff is feeding into entertainment into
comedians now they're cutting in their
self up all nice and short just to put
it out there because more people get it
that way yeah and also long like for
instance it's it's just and this is the
same
today's was years ago as is if you're
popular really popular in one in you
know in one type of media you'll be
hopefully popular in another type of
media you know I mean so if you're doing
but nowadays beef back in the day if you
were in a hot movie your shell be
awesome now being in a hot movie is
nothing you gotta bring on a hit show
and not including all the media like if
you're doing on something major media if
you it's actually better to be on a
video on YouTube who's got millions and
millions of likes showing a movie
tattooed though all like the trendy
stuff that's going on and you know what
I think a lot of these people do because
I've seen it if you can tell these
people who don't have talent they'll
watch comedians do a bit and they'll do
that bit but in their own words exactly
and good sees me to the point now it
seems like it's almost okay to steal on
the internet with this new generation
coming up cuz they'll do [ __ ] without
cuz to them it's not stealing it's just
borrowing it's just like yeah they don't
know how to put it on the internet you
mean yeah yeah so it's like I'm not
stealing it for not physically taking
your wallet you know oh there's your
joke like oh my job like a life raft
yeah yeah somebody made a meme with the
actual one of those inflatable beds
because when you put on your pants and
and when you want blood in your past and
ever actually inflatable bed oh yeah see
that's what they do people stealing [ __ ]
so when I do my next best show I'm gonna
do every good joke into a meme my next
one hour special will be a hundred
specials because I'm gonna do one man
dude I mean - that's only way to salvage
your [ __ ] so doesn't get super jacked it
to me
but then I've seen I've seen people do
my [ __ ] all over the place and now if I
know them or I'll hit them up no you
know that's my [ __ ] use me bro and other
people but you confront them yeah but
you know it some but I'm really honest I
got to look at myself go cable is it
it's a close to a joke that they could
have come up with themselves and there
it is I just let him know that I have
that joke as well but I'm not gonna
mention names there was a comic who did
one of my bits on George Lopez show and
it was it was a joke that I could see
maybe somebody else coming with but it
was word for word exactly the same and
then the thing was he was there when I
did that joke once at the Laugh Factory
so nice so the thing is this if if I see
you at the Laugh Factory and I have a
bit like that as soon as you get on
stage I'm gonna go eh dude you don't
have big you have the great funny I have
something really similar this is the way
it goes just so you know I could you saw
feel good about myself first if I leave
and I don't say nothing then you're
gonna and then you see me do it you know
a Joey Manuel a factory when I did that
bit how come you didn't you know say
anything right right so now you go and
just like does it happen a lot when you
were living with comics not so much your
face it'll do funny cuz Maddie
[ __ ] will make it to a big no
because I think when you when you're
hanging out with comics whoever comes up
whoever starts saying that funny thing
whatever it is first that it's theirs
and then all the other comics start
tagging it you know what I mean and
giving you I mean do you I've only
bought one joke my whole life and that
was from Felipe yeah yes the only joke
I've ever bought my whole life there was
because I think I had other stuff like
it so I'm like oh that's perfect but um
yeah that was that was the only joke
ever but but it was great it was a great
bit you know what I mean so it worked
and in and you know how it is I've
written jokes for other people that I'm
like it's not my style it's not my thing
but it's perfect for them
you know what I mean or I'll have a joke
that I wrote a while ago but I've never
really used it because it doesn't fit in
anything I have but I'll see somebody
with something also and do something
similar and I go hey dude there's this
joke I wrote a long time ago I don't you
added it's good and if you do it keep it
if not let me know and I'll just keep it
back when I was leaving new in the 13
yesterday I'm not wanting to lure 13
there's on black fur always thing over
there right he goes to the dispensary
and he walks he must have heard the
podcast he walked away doing your bid
which Pig the scrotum joke which one
I'll talk about we were talking about on
the podcast that what time you had that
bitter ball you bought these these boots
made of leather scrotum oh yeah they
were cast for that guy goes he told me
mr. budge away when they get wet they
get hard you said yeah
boost man a bull scrotum that was bull
scrotum with a man when you get hold of
shoes boots get tight oh yes I know it's
you know good ball joke when you gotta
do let's talk now we got to talk about
who's got to talk about maybe I talk
about her El Matador 20 years the
release Bristow yes gay brewing yes yes
a real Rivera Paul Rodriguez Ali
Raymundo Brad Williams yeah and Phillipe
s bar yeah he was in there you see him a
little shits not a little he's in there
for like two seconds but that guy was in
a movie you know in the movie the old
man with that uh the same dad from the
Joe Lopez show no no he is Cuban huh no
he's Puerto Rican and he was in a long
actor huh yeah he's been doing that
forever Beretta
he probably he's been doing a parrot he
was in he was in True Blood he was the
main my mom when they go back in time
and they showed the old vampires he was
the lead vampire guide True Blood but
he's a great guy man he just did me the
favor and stuff so anyway when I did a
matador and you know it was it all star
cast it wasn't all started together
today oh no at all well I couldn't get
it together there you know because it
was just really Harvey we did with no
money we did it on film
not even video and it was hard to get
everybody and it was him and yeah it was
really my film school like I look at it
now and like I don't show nobody that
now because I'm gonna
it's embarrassing I'm someone I'm a
better filmmaker now but it but I
watched it again the other day and it's
funny in a bad way your Hollywood
shuffle boy [ __ ] no you were doing these
bro that nobody had the balls to do
everybody wanted things to be done for
them yeah like Willie Barcena he was
waiting for a movie deal
you know Gabriel waiting and what he did
get it a matador even me mentality of um
they'll put you give you a special you
know what to give you this you know
what's happened to a gentleman Joey
Medina would be driving by Clinton you
know going to his pad yeah yeah and
watching those clubs right there by the
[ __ ] UH the nightclubs when I could
buy paramount and Dre Medina was like
man one thing I'm gonna be studying in
line right there cuz when I first met
Philippe he would say he was excited
about what of your movie going like cuz
you were hitting him up going hey man
hey I wrote a page in a page in movies
that's a minute that's a minute a
dialogue yeah
he started off with a little bit of
paper like this and you'll write the
dialogue he'll like brother he brought
work some more pages like crazy eyes bro
from orange a new black so writing a
script got any more of that okay you
know I would do that uh to be honest to
motivate myself because if I didn't tell
nobody I never then there was no
pressure huh yeah there was no pressure
on me to finish if I told somebody I'm
gonna do this and so now I told myself
[ __ ] I got to do it cuz I just told
somebody I'm gonna do an embarrassment
to face fear so I so I always push
myself for that and I always do my I
always have a certain goal no matter
what I did I did that horror movie that
missing one and I remember telling I
remember telling somebody I'm gonna win
an award I don't know what I'm gonna win
an award with this and I did I want five
Awards when it was done I didn't know
what it was and I wasn't Best Director I
was that was the one I cared I could hey
I didn't give a [ __ ] about the other
stuff but you know I did was seven then
you know then I shot my sitcom pilot in
and and I told people it's gonna get
picked up it's gonna works and it's
gonna look good enough to be on
television at now not like a sizzle reel
not like a practice it's gonna look
[ __ ] perfect and it really really
does man I mean now it's even tighter
than ever because I work
I because I had no money so I have all I
do is work on it more and more and
editing more and more and I get
different people to look at it and and I
get it tighter and tighter and it looks
like a real [ __ ] show man then one
thing you know let's just stop talking
about his Matsu daughter not to hate on
their little girl where they grow that
rightfully but all her videos you know
you gotta give to this our videos the
quality is perfect there's not a bad
video she put up sound Russell please
the reason is nowadays with iPhones and
you can't take a bad video it's there a
little bit of lighting it's techniques
probably like from lighting to sound
because she could afford it now yeah you
know and I see that all the time I see
people in Craigslist hey I'm look we're
at YouTube page we need a writer we need
to direct their camera person what they
need more is more talent that's what the
[ __ ] yeah but it's uh but it's really
hard honestly now to be bad you wrote
your movie toy everybody here that you
wrote your movie on our old school word
process I did yeah white and a brother
and if I wanted a broad if I wanted to
raise something how to use white out
like I have to go and write out and then
roll it back to the perfect line and
then type over it like that's what it
was it was like a typewriter it's weird
except it was more digital yeah digital
screen and you saw everything you wrote
and then you decide to print it huh yeah
and then you print it because I know
saving though right well no no no oh my
god no you yeah right there print and
print it whatever it print whatever you
would see in that little screen Wow
that's hardcore
yeah the next step up for the typewriter
dawg how did you meet up with the guy
that lived in Santa Monica or Torrance
the one I sold because he well working
in a movie that you produce today
the money el matador Jason James Locker
well Jason I knew from stand-up he was
doing open mic before I even started
doing stand-up and he was there was to
open my career with my friends him and a
guy named Kelly Parks who lives in San
Diego now but everybody else would have
my pad and paper and he got this new
joke it's a dick joke whatever you're
never gonna get anywhere with that
cleaner bro well that's I know I give
that advice a lot of people but uh no
yeah but so Jason helped me out Jason
financed El Matador you know he financed
no Matador with his credit cards he's
like hey let's do it let's make a movie
and then we just made it we both learned
so much on it man so I'm kind of glad
it's it's out now it's kind of like my
my thing and oh you got it you can go to
screening now.com
and you can you can stream it to 99 [ __ ]
yes Trini now calm calm the girl was at
the time she had broken up with her
boyfriend and she had like three bar
three trash bags full of spawn toys
spawn oh yeah I remember spawn was hard
right McFarlane Toys and she just put
him in my house and I remember I talked
to Jason hey bro do you like comic books
do you want two dolls you know I got
three bags full
three trash bags full of spawn toys huh
just give me whatever you want from
ruler check right there for $350 damn
you know what a percent that's why we
didn't shoot the last scene bro we
needed the money
we're at the house that was the scene
with Maria Martinez was in her house
yeah yeah yeah yeah Marylyn god bless
her she's in the movie everybody's
everybody that we know that this we own
and Peter and pops yeah pops was in it
and the one person we don't speak of
anymore he was in it the letter e and it
ends with not funny we don't say that
what is the movie about you know the
movies about our Matadors about this kid
who comes from a long line of Matador
families right or lay in his family
there's an heirloom of a pair of bronze
bull balls skinned heirloom dresser so
at one point a the the the bad guy in
the movie called it hotel and he has a
little [ __ ] looks just like him called
me a me too instead of many meet they
steal the ball so this guy wants to
become a matador to get the balls back
and that's kind of what the movies about
it's just a stupid idea and I got the
idea for the movie from that song on
Matador I just wanted to write something
called El Matador cuz I love that go I'm
gonna do a superhero who was a matador
there's this funny ass in a movie that
was like a little worm take he borrowed
from pulp fiction oh yeah I do it for
walking comes the boy here's Bruce Wayne
is the watch as a little fool shows up
like like Christopher Walken gives a
fool of solid balls I shot that scene
exactly like they shot the scene in Pulp
Fiction and the guy's giving the the kid
the cuckoo clock and he goes your father
when he crossed the border
you don't sport a patrolman we're gonna
take those so he goes he shoved it up he
put it somewhere where he knew they
wouldn't find it up his ass and every
hour on the hour
a cuckoo would shoot out of your
father's ass and go cuckoo everybody
crossing the border with him knew what
time it was
half past your father's ass another
scene where everyone eating every glass
Dean Austin I think or maybe another
blanket holding at the north end and
they're all sitting down for reservoir
dog men in black suits right now and
they're all talking they're all talking
and knowing stuff by and he's only nine
so then the next scene they're walking
man down the alley just like in the
movie Reservoir Dogs it because that was
you know as a filmmaker like you just
especially a movie like that I wanted it
to be spicy
yes poufy and I admire Geraldine a
borrowed more than that sure stranger
things straight out and I even did a
commercial do you remember no scene
there's at the time I had my first
cross-promotion yes my first my first
comedy CD which was below the belt
recording live at the fourth and B yes
that's right so they did a person
punching the balls yes yes so then in
the inner sets bail movie what the girl
the lead girl comes out and she has
flowers to give to the kids mom and he
goes hey those flowers for me no no
these for your mom she was but I have
something else for you and then they
both turned to the camera shield said
Joey Medina comedy CD it really was fun
but it was hard because nobody got paid
nobody got paid on this movie I know cuz
the German team thought it was one thing
about working with no money and somebody
said I gotta go you really can't big
yeah you can't make him some ah man I'll
give you more free and you know what was
hard was was Gabriel was work was
working a lot he was getting booked a
lot so it was that schedule was hard
then the little [ __ ] he were Marty's
Marty clever he was he's still in a lot
of films I was always working always
working and he was one of the main guys
and I'm and so I was always you know
shooting around it it was very devout
the drove
Marty clever he drove a big truck right
wasn't that big a struggle for bar for
ya
yeah hit you a big 4x4 on top on big old
tires right and then every time he would
leave everybody else take quiet just
watches he how he gets in through a hole
[Laughter]
but the cool thing about him he was
proportioned perfect like he wasn't like
he wasn't like Brad Williams kind of
[ __ ] II he was more like you know full
yeah he was buffing he was proportioned
no big header no he never big header big
but he was just muscular you heard of
Howard Stern Show - yeah yeah nice guy
he's cool I haven't seen him in a while
but coolest dude man I love Marty really
everybody in that film honestly was was
great except that one person that we
don't speak of but everybody was on the
fill-in and everybody loaned their time
and their energy to it man and it was a
fun project to do you know the only
thing I regret and regret missing the
after the last thing I heard was a lot
of fun everybody was dressed in drag for
that Gabriel so Emilio Rivera is in drag
you know from sunset man are you he's in
drag no more Tricia's huh yeah pretty
much
but it was hilarious so we you know it
was it was I learned more about
filmmaking making that movie then I
learned about anything else I lessons to
this day still I still do because [ __ ] I
learned shooting that film to me that
was $15,000 of film school you know what
I mean what took so long for the mood to
come out now no no it came out he came
out right away
it was enough for about oh yeah no it's
still in Netflix you can get it on DVD
on Netflix but don't go to Netflix I
don't get paid for that but I sold it -
what happened was I sold it to a company
called maverick films and we just played
Yanni no no Danny's that's not Danny's
this is a company out of Florida and
they basically broke even we broke even
so that was good and then I just wanted
it out there and it was so I sold I did
a contract with him for over 10 years
you lost on the sallowness telling of it
right yeah I didn't daddy make money at
all I didn't make money at all I'm are
you telling me you know Philippos you
wanted out there yeah I just everyone
thought he paid you know
yeah and that was it you know I worried
about Jason cuz he's gonna finance
everything no no your resume
yeah yeah and so now there's a new
company that came out called screening
now that's if you're a filmmaker listen
people in you wants and you want and you
have you have no way to get your stuff
out there you know what I mean this
check these cats out there like the poor
man's Netflix so I met them for for
another project that I shot and I said
hey miss him and I got the rights to
this movie I shot you know a whole bunch
of years ago and you've got you know all
these cats in it that are doing great
now and and he watched it and I go and I
was making apologies I'm gonna do this
not as good as I you know my [ __ ] now
but he saw it he goes dude it's funny I
like it he goes you know yeah let's do
it
so we made a deal you know um
he didn't give me any money for it it's
a 50/50 split so that you know it's a
two to 95 or to 99 to rent meant to rent
but to stream and after
credit card charges I get half of that
so hopefully now I can make some money
but still yet like even Jason I told him
I had a meeting with Jason the other
night I told my miss and I go dude you
were there from the beginning so
whatever I make you get half of that and
he's like man you didn't have to tell me
about that I'm like I know but I'm not a
dick so cuz I'm honest you know so so
and my thing is this I just want to see
it out there you know I don't mean it
makes money doesn't it probably won't
but I just want people to see it and
just have fun with it because there's
all these cats that people recognize now
from television and from films and
everybody that they can watch you know
in a in a 16-millimeter movie that was
shot with no [ __ ] money with bad
lighting and it's hilarious it's bad you
know you watch something funny but it's
bad it's kind of like that one of those
things man you're standing right there
but the shadow is the camera man real
candles scene one of my favorite sitcoms
ever is Arrested Development there was a
scene when they were I see the [ __ ]
other cameraman standing there on the
side I see him like I'm like holy [ __ ]
how do you [ __ ] how you messed that up
Tina did on purpose
I did also could you could tell you know
know speaking of seen the cameraman I
think you see the cameraman in the movie
Rocky - really rocky - or under fight
with a guy you can see the kepco 'they
could the guy was running with a camera
though first I'm gonna move in with the
camera yeah right right the original
Rocky was the first time to use a
Steadicam yeah when he ran up the stairs
his time in history said he cannot use
canticle running with a camera hub
before with Wow so before film was
standing still yeah or you had any
tracks
Travis camera you need to track and now
it's different like on my sitcom I have
this thing called a ronin that I used
and Rosen it's uh it's like a handle
thing but it has a a gyro like a
gyroscope thing that you put the camera
on so matter no matter where you put
moved how to move the handles the camera
always stay steady yeah so it's kind of
like a Steadicam same principle so we
use that on this show but you know and
then every trick I learned dude on
shooting something I learned it and I
use it the next time I use it the next
time and it becomes easier and easier
and I'm doing really well shooting with
no money man because I'm learning how to
do it but I own all my equipment my
camera is my lighting my sound I own
everything you don't product on my own
grip [ __ ] I don't all of it so I don't
have to spend money renting something
you know how much you spend on location
spots for your movie well unfair adore
yeah no matter I really spend anything I
did favors like you know the restaurant
yeah all right we're gonna use a [ __ ]
restaurant tomorrow 10:00 basically if
you ought to be in the movie that you
had to contribute some his car remember
the helicopter drink was there that
whole [ __ ] time cuz they were looking
for somebody we thought it was us oh so
you snatched it from that no what the
helicopter scene no no it's we shot when
we were shooting that scene out in the
street we're in a valley in Burbank yeah
there was a there was a hell police
helicopter we thought they were trying
to look for us so we're like [ __ ] we
gotta keep shooting and then what they
were doing they were looking for
somebody I guess somebody broke
somebody's house but the thing was I had
to do that
that sound [ __ ] me up because the
whole scene is a [ __ ] helicopter
flying around so we had to figure out
how to how to clean the sound up it was
such it's so [ __ ] difficult like it
took me longer to edit that movie than
it did to shoot the movie like it was
much like it no I was probably about a
year maybe
editing that movie and you did it on
film so you guys were cutting spicing no
we did it on we transferred the film
over to video and this was the old avid
machine so we're still at Ohio's
an old process and ya guys have it's
just another editing system you know
that alone you see the film on it and
then you could no no because we did we
transferred the film so you take film
and you put it into video formats but
the tapes are like this big
like old beta there was yeah he returned
I sure yeah yeah it's like those and
then so they edit on those on those
tapes so it was very difficult so you
know it it's but it's now things are so
much different I had it on my laptop at
[ __ ] star will even know in that
movie huh no no did you offer my role
probably but he probably I don't know
why didn't I don't know remember but uh
yeah there was no issue I don't my name
is big because Billy would I mean Willie
was probably the most busiest comics out
of all of us during that time so he was
probably never there yeah I know
oh me Benny mana and yeah Benny was in
it Morty Moreno was in it as well a
whole bunch of cats were do almost
everybody I remember that scene with in
a Buster movie rented right screening
now.com on the bus you know died the
same people waving at the people leaving
in the bus or anybody I had people like
put their heads down wear a hat over
there
you remember Philippe in when I shot
that scene the extras in the bus we got
them from the Home Depot we I promised
them five dollars and a sandwich right
so we filled up the bus but the
cameraman that I had [ __ ] up and he
put the wrong film in the camera
he put the film for daylight instead of
the dark film like so we had to redo the
whole thing again so what I did was I
just got the crew in the people that
were doing other stuff I put him in
there go look just put your head down
you know just to wear a hat like do all
this and then I shot it from a lower
perspective so you really don't see too
many faces for some of the shots so
that's kind of the way
cheating bro no making Sun in a movie
with
I'm here to Eternity right which ones
that one oh yeah oh here to return the
what the one with Humphrey Bogart final
name please and you came in here
Casablanca Casablanca at the end of the
scene when am I supposed to be Humphrey
Bogart and the French police and there
under the airport and his lover his
lover is leaving that I found out that
that's not really them standing the
little people but they wanted to look as
far
oh yeah there was a guy a little person
to Bogart and another person at the
French cop and then when they're waving
it's just their voice is talking but
it's them right there what's that Hobbit
or the Hobbit the that's what that's
what they do like they'll if they want
to show like somebody bigger than
somebody they'll sit him in the table
and it on the camera it looks like
they're sitting directly in front of
each other but actually one person is
closer to the camera than the other and
then that what that gives you a
perspective different perspective so the
person who's further away from the
camera looks small and the other one
looks bigger but on camera because it's
flat it looks like they're right in
front of each other I know man cool when
I saw Eddie Murphy for the first time I
think god damn Axel Foley I thought you
were 6-3 he's little knock big screen
it's how you shoot stuff it's angles
it's what you really can manipulate a
look on a camera you're you know on the
screen anyway you want you just got to
know what you're doing and there's all
kinds of tricks and filmmaking dude that
learn all that stuff for watching
magicians in Vegas that's right he said
that guy had mirrors right which one
when you were backstage at that guy's
butt the magician show you tell me one
time reflect you were backstage and you
saw other guys tricks well yeah well oh
yeah that's right I did I did a at the
Monte Carlo
I forgot the magician there he'd the way
he does tricks I mean the way he does
the tricks I could see him but because I
was backstage like it was a black night
for him so all his tour all his tricks
were back there and it was me and Paul
Rodriguez we were performing at the
Monte Carlo
so like there was this there's a thing
where he makes there's a empty like cage
and then he makes a car appear and then
disappear and they do that with mirrors
the car is always there they just moved
the mirror inside and then when the the
mirrors look like pointed up it just
looks like there's the place is black
yeah it's blank like there's nothing in
there that's called an illusion illusion
just I feel make ado filmmaking is all
tricks man it's just you manipulate the
film or you manipulate the image to get
an emotion or a reaction or to get a
certain look or you know what I mean so
it's uh it's kind of like being a
magician but when you're making a movie
and it's fun dude it's fun as [ __ ] I
love filmmaking so [ __ ] much you know
I just can't wait I make a living doing
it that would be nice you direct it
already I redirected a bunch of stuff
music videos little sketches shorts you
know and now that the last thing I
direct it was a sitcom oh and comedy
specials are directed for comedy
specials so that was fun you know and
then another one that we did we did the
all-star comedy uh
a Latina teen all-star loser
yeah the Latin Palooza I did a chola
comedy slam but I also we just did the
all-star comedy show with the dog dirty
show with the you know Vegas the Vegas
show that dirty at 12:30 so I just
directed that and that's gonna be on
screening now as well so you know trying
to do [ __ ] gotta make [ __ ] happen son
I'm busy and I'm doing all this [ __ ] but
I'm broke as [ __ ] I don't know how that
works because there's homeless people
who aren't doing nothing and they had
the same amount of money as I do that's
just not fair there were no teeth should
I write now broken ribs he directed his
own horror film that's cool but that
next time I do something man home you
know hey you guys are in it let's do it
so I'm this I'm a screen e where can
they get it again
screening now just go online it's called
screening now calm and that's it's like
a Netflix but they only have a few
titles right now cuz this literally I
think it's like a month old the company
the company is a month or two month old
and but they're gonna have a lot of
stuff in you can see El Matador for
$2.99 you stream it there there's a
trailer so you can see the trailer on
there as well and and check it out you
know represent you're gonna like the
movie or you
and don't go thinking I don't expect
like a [ __ ] masterpiece alright don't
go there with high hopes high
expectations you know think you'll see
some Steven Spielberg [ __ ] just know we
made it with no money we made it with
like a flashlight and some duct tape and
a bunch of funny guys so if you go in
with that expectation you're gonna enjoy
the movie just don't go in there
thinking man you told me that the main
actor or the mustard or he quit quit I'm
acting I think so yeah yeah yeah Andrew
a bar was his name he's a really
good-looking dude he was a good actor
and I don't know you know I don't know
what happened but the girl ADA is uh
Doug Williams his wife oh yeah that's
that's the girl the main girl in the
movie is ADA ADA blah well I remember
when we're shooting a movie you know how
you have um you have bridges of grandeur
yes right I was thinking yeah my head
like yeah man what if I don't stand up
see didn't like it'll be funny ass his
style back then Abena him
happy management Rick yeah some real
Faro movie bro boy [ __ ] he's doing now
oh yeah that's me hater I'm just saying
yes it sucks because he he has a power
in Hollywood to do whatever he wants and
the last few things he's done is not
that well I take it back the last thing
he did that I saw Lester the Western was
[ __ ] funny jokes and why cuz I went in
there with low expectations I went in
there with low expectations I thought
it's gonna be like parents or whatever
the [ __ ] the other ones he made but it
was I loved it I thought it's really
funny that Sandman hire John Medina
that's right director film for you yeah
man what happened I think they also like
Jack Black him and those actors they
become parents and I don't wanna change
bro yeah nasty funny [ __ ] I used to put
isn't watching it yeah like ice cube bro
nobody watercourse [ __ ] no no he's
traveling I know he's me but he still
got that pissed off face you know but
he's just pissed off in a nice way I
guess man no matter what you put ice
cube in he's a same ice cube right yeah
Cooper the gynaecologist bro man let me
see those legs
see what's up in this [ __ ] Ice
Cube and a psychologist bro you got
problem with your legs
I should be romantic let me see them
legs you see them toes ice cubes just
dude it's but everybody again you've got
to reinvent yourself you got to kind of
just what's the fun of it six to six six
two six two five seven three one zero
five that number again is six two six
two five seven three one zero five in
the in the beautiful city of La Puente
that that's right yeah a bad boy our
four I hooked up with Antonio from
Flacco's tacos in Berkeley the best
vegan tacos ever loud us is their number
Klee
flock of tacos because we're talking
about open up our vegan restaurant
together are here now
here in LA right so this fool gives me a
20 pound Lisa you give me a 10 pounds of
corn dough masa corn masa to make flour
tortillas bro are we prepared are you
doing master smash to go the dough and
make tortillas bro we may talk with your
delicious bro we may stop this we're
gonna [ __ ] to make bro we might give him
away
we have how do you guys like that okay
damn so Lisa are you cooking Mexican now
vegan bro nice nice so piss again I get
my tamales at Costco dude a dope I love
the host know they're good I think
they're real Mexican people know of
course I've heard they were really good
going there they some it's like a dozen
in the Costco brand illegally fat though
they're good ones you know man
I used to buy those tamales they the
coming that can [ __ ] male yeah tamale
with chili in it so white trash little
party right there hungry bro I love my
teeth
I love the crunch he was eating that
[ __ ] just to lose weight it's trust me
for munching dawg
well this is true they say you know how
they say pasta is bad for you cuz of the
starch if you cook it al dente or
whatever which a little a little hard
hard off it doesn't have the starch so
that's that's the healthy way to eat it
look auntie yeah ten days that's a hell
new you will get the starch so it's less
carbs now us told me that you know
you have a bundle you to get their
comedy condo house like yeah we're
[ __ ] prison bro I mean you could have
minutes of rockin Top Ramen dude we
learned we we were the top ramen chefs
you do you [ __ ] around with ketchup bro
genie style that's all
who took the crushed peppers it comes
only with that packet so you got a
[ __ ] ad [ __ ] to it then and then that
that's before the 99 cent store [ __ ] now
forget it you can go crazy with the
charity nice do I always have that fig
apple jack zero Apple Devils Monsanto
Jack's house anyway one section just for
other grimaldo bro who's Adam oh yeah he
was in the film dude Paul Rodriguez was
in there angel yeah he played he played
his the [ __ ] his his father's angel and
then Paul Rodriguez played Alex playing
the angel he just he even says it in the
family and I'm just here to do it
director favor and the funny thing is
the most expensive day of shooting for a
matador was that film because I mean
that that's that scene with Paul
Rodriguez cuz I had a rent of studio
because we hung midgets from ropes and
they would Williams and tiny camera you
know uh
Tanya Lee was one of they were dressed
as angels but you could see the rope
like the ropes are there everything like
thick ropes and so Paul I told Paul said
listen I don't know what I'm gonna shoot
this at maybe like in a garage or
something it was like nine I hear and he
gave me $2,000 to rent the studio and
the [ __ ] still came late but it
doesn't matter he paid for it so dude
yes so he paid for the studio and the
lights to shoot that scene you know and
it's funny because that seemed that the
the film got all scratched and [ __ ] and
I had a [ __ ] fix it was hard man it
was hard but it's funny watching [ __ ]
and one of the midgets was in a was in a
wheelchair so she's dressed like an a
little she's in an electric wheelchair
going around Paul like this in a circle
it's so bad but yet so good
it is my sharknado that's what it is
it's my sharknado so if you like that
kind of [ __ ] watch this movie on
screening now calm little people paying
for like four hours because there was a
because I had to pay a guy to put him up
and then I couldn't afford to keep him
the whole time so we better leave him
there until we're ready to finish and
then we took we brought him down
stretching that dollar dog well I did I
produced a [ __ ] there you go
I never wanted to be a producer but then
at the end of our Matador when I'm doing
the credits I'm going holy [ __ ] I
produce this like I actually I go also
that's what a producer does you know
like I didn't know I'm like I don't be a
producer I don't know what a [ __ ]
producer was I just saw a camera
directors but then racing what a
producer does is directs the film before
you know before you direct that's what
you do is you know and my style of
directing is like I direct like a
producer and I produced like a director
so so when I film it's it's all
everything's connected everything flows
well you know I mean well you just asked
I producer sunglasses in the cigar sound
again for free but yeah who's your
inspiration that you think I know that
you didn't know could you wake up one
day I want to be a filmmaker or
something that eventually you just
jumped in somebody on that you you you
don't know who it is
Morris char now Morris Charny was my
fifth grade teacher and what happened in
fifth grade was this he had a 8
millimeter film of kids in the class the
year before doing a Batman sketch like
and there was no sound it was just film
and I remember he played it he played it
on the screen and like I remember the
person dressed up the Batman had like at
Halloween Batman thing and his bat-rope
was a jump rope and I remember watching
that I swear to God somewhat I remember
like my jaw dropped man I'm like I want
to do that I want to make him this is
amazing so in seventh grade
two years later door was born yeah
sounds great I bought from it from
another teacher in my junior high school
I bought a stolen film camera projector
and a screen from Board of Education and
for 50 bucks and I made a little King
Kong movie like that the reason Kong
movie was because I had a gorilla mask I
had my my brother wear the gorilla mask
I will he had he wore a fake fur coat
and he had gorilla hands right but it
was funny and then he picked up this guy
yeah he picks up this doll house and
then so he picks it up all the like
furniture on it falls on his face cuz
you know how it's only got one side and
then and then you can see his wrist and
then I had a ship like a model ship I
put in the bathtub and I shot that
Midway yeah then I shut my NATO
fraternity shot I shut out a video shot
of my sister going oh my god here's King
Kong and then I cut to a Barbie doll
with his hand up like that and King Kong
with the wrist you can see the wrist
grabs
I did like a whole cow movie 4 3 cuz
back then those 8 millimeter films were
3 minutes and 10 seconds long Wow
so I had it and then you time it you see
it on the camera and you just keep
shooting because there's no editing you
edit on the camera you just keep
shooting it and like in the order it's
supposed to be in and that was the first
thing I ever directed in seventh grade
and I thought that was the [ __ ] but then
I got into boxing's deep into boxing so
I filmmaking you know took two you know
we went on the back burner but I always
loved filmmaking after that and it was
Morris channeled so matter of fact true
story when I when I made our Matador I
was so proud that I made a [ __ ] movie
even though it was that movie I was so
proud that I found my teacher Morris
Charny and I sent him a VHS of El
Matador he was say you kidding me you
know and I told him I gonna return to
sender I know you inspired me to do this
bad and
[Laughter]
another teacher rascal well because he
stole it from the school actually my
shop teacher and I told them I said yeah
I want to make a movie and it's queenie
came with a stand make you put the
screen down or up and it had to project
the whole thing had all three pieces the
camera shield heavier because they also
Board of Education property of Ali's
[Laughter]
[ __ ] stapled on oh yeah yeah because
I we stayed in contact a little bit
after that and then not like maybe about
a year later I uh a headline Caroline's
in New York and invited him so he
actually got to see me do stand-up well
the whole package and I'm like dude is
my fifth grade teacher who's the coolest
teacher in the [ __ ] earth man I love
that guy Morris char now I don't know I
lost contact with him but a yellow joy
[Laughter]
no I don't know why that is I want to
find that I want to find it bitchin yeah
it was great was funny I still remember
making it was [ __ ] we had I think
soldiers like army so pointy so you see
this little Puerto Rican girl pointing
right then I cut to a white Barbie doll
with blond hair I don't know if it was
your movie or you were directing or
you're starring in a movie you call me
up a master in this movie and I met you
at some big
sparking of Valley and some guy was
shooting a movie in the park oh that was
no Matador and it was all a little doll
laying on the floor on the freeway on
the streets I remember shooting in a
park in the valley info Matador and I
had the midgets on that scene - who look
but yeah dude it you know that's that's
how filmmaking that's like any any art
does you get better just by doing it
more and more and more and you know when
I shoot my own stuff I don't I don't
mind [ __ ] up because it's my [ __ ] you
know but if somebody hires me to do
something a music video something I'm
really really careful because it's their
money you know I mean but but then you
know the more I shoot man I only shoot
when I know it's gonna be right I don't
[ __ ] right could some people I got a
lot of friends now you know that'd be -
hey hey hey I got the sketch idea Hey
and I'm always open like I'm like I'll
help you out
because you're my friend but then you
don't hear back from them anymore you
know what I mean they're like I'm like
dude I'm not gonna chase you to do your
[ __ ] idea yeah chase me yeah if you
want if you I'll do it I'm there for you
but you know if I gotta use all my
equipment a lot of equipment then you
got to bring me help I'm gonna be pip
packing all this [ __ ] picking up all
this because I keep on I've so much [ __ ]
I have it in storage like I'm not gonna
go up there and [ __ ] load up a
[ __ ] van with all my [ __ ] by myself
and load it back just to do you a little
[ __ ] favor you got to help me help
you and then I'll help you out that way
you know but that's who I am because you
know I mean sometimes I saw you got his
friends and sometimes I remember when I
had no equipment and I wanted to do
something he was hard to beg for
somebody a man could you help me out
with this could you help me out with
that so now when when I have a friend
that needs something I'm totally down
but long as I can do it and it's not
crazy and they have to pay for
everything I don't pay for it you know
what I mean but I lend my talent and my
equipment and I'm like let's do this and
your benevolence yes and let's make this
[ __ ] happen are you sure I'm
sure lost lamb
that was are you quit your equipment to
know that we rent it well actually it
was a production company that I sold
that show - it was their equipment we're
working people watch total slammer
jean-louis lamb I think it's on Hulu you
can get it there who's in it on there is
Emilio Rivera brought him back out of
retirement yeah let's see Marty Marino's
in it how do you do many men are right
you know the best the best that was
actually I think I know the best that
was um a medial medial destroyed it and
then Gilbert asked about kill MIT 200
and and DJ couch didn't he
DJ coach killed it that was that was
really good and and it was fun making it
man and I made it because somebody
somebody wanted me to make that show so
I saw I pitched the idea and all that
literally all the money they gave me to
make that thing I put on screen
I didn't pay myself anything just to
make it look good yeah because it and to
make it look as good as I could and
there was mistakes that happened I could
go back trust me on me I'll do things
differently like that there was a I had
a intern that was supposed to do this
put like a video on the screen every
time a comic went up and once the show
started the [ __ ] just forgot and I was
stuck with that [ __ ] image that I had
on which was a temporary image
throughout the whole show so I I would
do that different I would do a lot of
things different and be yourself
definitely make a [ __ ] I work my ass off
me I wanna be myself so homie yeah me
and my girlfriend at the time we work my
ass off on that we worked our ass off on
that we really did she worked she worked
just as hard as me if not more and
there's no half give her a big shout out
cuz shut up broke her ass on that and I
couldn't have done it without her and um
but but it was I felt really good when I
did it cuz I'm like I did that with
$14,000 that's it $14,000 I hadn't had a
[ __ ] venue with 2,000 people in it I
had you know four or five cameras I had
crew and to give you the big difference
was I did a Latin Palooza was a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars Wow
so that's the difference I did I did a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar job
with fourteen thousand dollars melt
really extremely the the UM million
dollar TV has to rent it oh yeah we had
a while to be more expensive to rent
yeah no it that cost I think it was
three grand to rent tax returns three
thousand dollars yeah that's right that
when they came with their shitty
security with [ __ ] old ladies and OMA
and it was [ __ ] yeah they were like
there was there's like [ __ ] 2000
Xolos in the audience I had a flashlight
yeah these old ladies and these old men
they
like yeah they weren't doing any
security at all you know and then we had
a Frankie J was there we had a mr.
Caponi you know yeah it was a good show
man yeah it was it was a good show it
really was a good show the talent was
good in the show love him the show yeah
there was these two girls that came up
there they were the dancers so we had
these two girls go up there like she
they would walk up the actors Noel GE
was in it you know we they walked him up
but it was good man again it was a
learning experience you know of every I
think every filmmaker and and I think I
saw Martin Scorsese say this they they
could all do every project they had over
again they would do it differently they
would do something that they learned
they were like man I wish I would have
done that I showed it done they're so
much older than that and that's the
truth you know it's it's it's never ever
perfect to other people maybe perfect
but to you you like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] up
here I missed up here I'll see this or
I'll see you know you can see a
reflection off a camera or the lighting
or something nobody else will see it but
you know it's there and that's like [ __ ]
next time I won't I'll make sure I'll do
this I'll make sure I'll do that you
know shooting the sitcom that I just
shot I learned a lot I learned because
it I did that again all by myself I made
it I made like a half a million dollar
looking sitcom for $4,000 and that was
[ __ ] very difficult to do but again
it's all comes from experience right
yeah they just a lot of planning it's
all planning oh yeah would you tell or
any young person listening they want to
get into film [ __ ] just start
shooting man grab your [ __ ] film no
no your film school no no no wait the
money yeah yeah make take that money and
film something learn get people who know
what they're doing and learn from them
and YouTube I'll be editing right now
and now and I'll be doing something I'm
like [ __ ] I don't know how to do this
I'll go on YouTube and I find out how to
do it and there's some other
[ __ ] I just did it I just saw
my girl right I'll do that I'll learn
that's how I learned to edit myself
nobody taught me how to edit I learned
it's lumber on YouTube edit I know how
to make rabbit Ford's I googled how can
I make my rabbit afford and I got told
me and the lady in Japan show me how to
make a Ford see there you go there it's
true you can learn anything about
anything on [ __ ] YouTube and it's
just and then you learn different angles
different ways to do it you know I did
Oh Matador there's special effects in it
not all matter I'm sorry
missing where you know
grandma grandma's head gets smashed in
with a bat and blood everywhere a woman
a girl gets hit by a car and she flies
off all that [ __ ] I really know how to
do on YouTube you know and that was it
how did you do that come on it's okay
great looks great it's composites it's
just composites it's like it's the same
trick is it's the same thing like you do
in Photoshop except you're doing it with
moving pictures instead of uh so you
know so for instance okay like the
grandmas laying there right you see her
laying down on her heads there so I
shoot that then I shoot I put an X where
her head is right and I don't move the
camera the trick is you don't move the
camera then I put a watermelon there
with a wig like the grandmas hair the
white here with guts and blood in it
smash that with a bat and then you take
those two images because the camera
never moves they just go right on top of
each other and then you wrote a scope
[ __ ] around it so when there you see the
bat coming down you start erasing
grandma's face and you start putting
blood there and then you see it and then
when you let it go when you let it
render boom grandma gets her head
smashed in that's what it looks like
that's that's the trick that's just
that's a special-effects trick yeah
special effects in this very simple
special effects trick anybody could do
it
how can you shoot somebody not funny and
make them funny dude I've seen really
I've seen people specials without the
laugh track and and you got to sweeten
it up you just got to sweeten it up
because sometimes it's not maybe the
joke was good but just the audience
didn't feel it at that second and you're
gonna put something out there on the
screen you can't have that you can't
have us you got to bring up the laughter
you got to make that laughter rich you
know what I mean and that's enough yeah
yeah I know man I'm gonna shot Last
Comic Standing I'm there to use my
laughs from Last Comic Standing and put
them on Kathy Griffin's that leaves you
bomb oh wow there you go there you go
that's true that's why everything can I
watch the body and see like I don't hear
the laughs a stripper did I wash her
Dewhurst and then I heard
that's why all everything gets recorded
separately when you shoot a special
comedy special the audience's
microphones their complete their
separate so madam attacks yeah so you
have these tracks separate that you can
[ __ ] with play with and put everywhere
you want one trick what you do is to
make it better you you don't make them
louder you don't bring the volume up
because that sounds weird what you do is
you w you double track them so you take
that same track you layer it you'd let
you make a copy of the same track you
layer it on top of it and then it has a
natural loudness that doesn't sound like
you put the volume up it just sounds
like there's double the people they're
more powerful to fragment sound only to
have a joke in an inlet your bomb in the
audience right now there are people on
the other side of the world laughing
their ass off and they don't know why
[Laughter]
coming up coming up I got in April in a
probably and I'm sorry in March I'm
gonna be in in Reno I'll be at the Laugh
Factory Reno and in July I know I'm
doing the know in April I'm doing
flappers in Burbank in July I'm doing
the Tropicana in Vegas and just go to
join me Dina calm you can see all the
other [ __ ] I'm doing this Saturday
people are built on over in downtown LA
January 21st next week Atlanta Georgia
January 27 through 29 at the punchline
and regardless of what Donald Trump said
about that guy Louis this neighborhood
is where that guy Louis's from is
bucking head and made me tell you man
that's a rich at neighborhood I don't
know what Donald Trump was talking about
[ __ ] Buckhead and Atlanta it's a lot
of people with money there also there
were 11 know February
I'll be at at with I'll be with Mike
Epps in the Orlando Cincinnati yeah boo
Mike Epps in Orlando in Orlando
Cincinnati Raleigh North Carolina Dallas
Chicago and also being Pleasant in
California at Tommy T's and San Antonio
improv River stand we're gonna be a well
the show today we're gonna know cuz it's
Friday but you know
and then the show Friday Friday Friday
I'm gonna be attitude I'm gonna be it's
not the company pop up comedy wash up I
mean Rose me tonight but I mean that's
lastly we're gonna find you at Joey
Medina go to Jeremy Dina calm you know
my Twitter which is Joey Medina comic my
Instagram is Joey Medina comic and my
facebook is Germany in a fanpage
shout-out to David Rodriguez for the
shirts from his family's bakery in La
Puente love roller disco also thank you
everybody who has been leaving comments
on itunes keep coming with those
comments please review our show on
soundcloud give us a four stars give us
four stars on itunes to share the
podcast all your friends it's random no
war so full podcast check out join
Medina's movie el matador our screeners
are screening now.com screening now.com
and he young man's coming up we have one
coming up this weekend dude who you got
bingum's all's been Gonzalez who's that
bull from San Diego
no it's from LA does that website comedy
show Guney show do the beauty school so
Benji from over there oh that's from San
Diego yeah Benji Benji was last name
frog friend or whatever he's off ser
another San Diego charger left we're sad
they're coming here I'm back I thought
that for the only you know funny I'm the
only person that can block the Raiders
from going to Las Vegas is the city of
San Diego
how's that because they have a bowling
right they could boat on they still
because those charges even though they
left our ladies to have a vote as the
Chargers well if San Diego's pissed off
while they do it
yeah so San Diego could get the Raiders
if they're smart if they're smart to
ours and so why would they get the
Raiders and give them a new stadium what
they don't want to give it to the
Chargers yes true what's up with that
dude I don't know man Joe Medina build
him a stadium Joey Medina right here
what's up balls of steel
you go toilet right here good night
everybody thank you for listening
we're so full